and if Putin will lose come from your
heated well build nice house in center
of Kiev and after a few hours you're
already beggar people killed in the cars
putting it to the fan because NATO is
expanding
not true basically I would say the
rational lying the real battle with
ostomel and the Russian plane failed
there Greener like a kind of
avant-garde of our resistance this is a
European War
my name is Lorraine sokramonesi I write
for the Italian major Italian aliens
paper corriere delacera which is the
oldest daily in Italy was founded more
than 150 years ago I'm 65 years old in a
month and I'm working for this newspaper
since when I was very young just after
the university so it's now 40 years more
than 40 years that I'm working for this
paper
and I study philosophy and since I was
when I was very young I started to be a
journalist I like I have a grandfather
with a journalist and I've been 20 years
correspondent in Jerusalem since from
the early 80s till 2000 2001
and then I've been of course at the time
a lot in the Middle East a lot in
Lebanon at the time the the
israeli-palestinian question was really
the central question of the Middle East
and then of course I cover Lebanon Iraq
Afghanistan
[Music]
and I was in Ukraine I came in Ukraine
2014 for the event maidan and after
maidan I followed I remember in
particular the Baltimore fight
and at the time for us Western
journalists was still possible to cross
I came to Kiev but then I went also to
Donetsk I went to the so-called
autonomous region and I remember
covering in particular the tragic event
the shooting down air Malaysian airplane
with a lot of civilians killed almost
300 a lot of children
and there was a particular story because
I found out there was a local pro-ration
soldier who openly told me they shot it
down so I was called also of the
international Trail I was kind of a
witness I testimony in my experience
there
foreign
[Music]
by the European press but also I think
in general by the international press
was more or less forgotten was not taken
seriously was seldomly followed if I
look back and this last year before or
24th of February if I look back at the
last eight years I remember a few
moments in which the story came out and
came back to our attention the first one
which I came on to my mind is recently
catch crisis in 2018 if you're not
mistaken when the Russian built the
bridge closed the azov sea and even took
some of the two or three Ukrainian boats
I remember I came I went to mariopo and
it was a bit of flurry of attention
a wave of article of stories but then
again the story went down the easy way
in which the Russians got Crimea
so the idea was that Ukraine was somehow
defending itself it was not a real army
it was uh still the kind of beginning of
a kind of army there was no comparison
between the strength of the two
it was more a kind of army of volunteer
the story of the azov
Battalion came out very often in this
case the Russian propaganda was very
strong maybe not Neo-Nazi but Extreme
nationalists with neo-native value this
vastica story came out many many times
there was a kind of suspicious you know
vis-a-vis the Ukrainian resistance
[Music]
I would say that in Italy in particular
having these long strong relation of
between Italy and Russia this is a
chapter in itself which is interesting
because Italy you know Europe is similar
but it's composed by different states
with different stories different
elements
so there was a lot of Sympathy for the
Russian too and a lot of attention to
the donuts donbath people to the reason
of the
independencies the pro-ration we are
journalists following the story from the
other side and Russia and welcoming them
the Russian army
and the Ukrainian resistant composed of
ambiguous element let's say
that why when
the Russian attacked the Russian
invasion happened
in European generally in Italy in
particularly
the idea was in one day the Russian will
win
the Russian will take over
that was the General perceptive form the
little journalist the young newcomer to
the big commentator to the politician to
the historian the idea was
Russian will win in no time and I
remember the first of March well the
first that means
six days after the beginning of the
Russian in seven day one week after
being a Russian video I wrote I called
my editoration in Chief and in Milano
and I told him we should write a story
kind of a comment with a question mark
and if Putin will lose
I mean change the narrative maybe it's
not so easy maybe it's not so clear it's
not so
impossible
the Ukrainian will resist and will even
take over we'll be able to resist and
that's wow impossible you're crazy you
understand nothing the paper told me
this time you don't cover Ukraine that
was told by Korea delacera in Milano and
I tell you on the 26th of February I was
supposed to go to Somalia
for a story of February for the Western
world
talk about media commentator there were
two kind of preconceptions first if
Russian attack will win second Russia
will not attack the narrative was it's
only a bluff
the American are the usual and more
monger they understand nothing they
failed in Afghanistan they failed in
Iraq
and look they will not under they don't
understand the Putin is bluffing
and I myself I was dubious
but I told let me go I will cost you 2
000 Euro I go there I go in hotel let
others write if something happened I am
there and they tell me no you don't go
so when they call me
I was taken by surprise and I came
foreign
flight to to Warsaw and to come in by by
car and then
from um live
but that day the moldavian airspace was
closed and I remember I went to vanish
because there was a local flight to go
to Moldavia and the flight was closed so
I went back to Milano and I took a
flight to Warsaw to Poland
and I remember calling my editor in the
car because I went there and then back
was five or six hours in the car telling
him you see it's already Europe
an airspace is closing you have to talk
about Europe
a NATO country for me was extremely
difficult from Luis
to come to
a cave
the train wearing total confusion and it
was no it was very cold was knowing I
don't know if you were here but it was
really tough and then I found a young
guy who took me by car and I had to
arrived here when there was the maximum
attend by the Russian to enter I didn't
know that we we enter under shelling
what from the road we had to leave the
major Motorway from leopoly because the
motorway itself was bomb I saw bodies of
people killed in the cars
I was called by my newspapers talking
about the situation right now
in the early morning of the attack of
the Russian aggression and that was
about five o'clock it was the commit six
one hour later and asked me to come
foreign
[Music]
I was thinking there will be a partisan
War that was our thing there will be a
resistance inside Russian lines inside
Russian occupied territory
distance
they were
self-organized Committee of people
resisting with hunting gun not with with
machine gun with hunting and with all
First World War pistols to defend
themselves and they say they will
organize but my my I consider obvious
that the Russian would have taken Kiev
and my first concern I remember I didn't
know even where to go
many journalists were living many
children were escaping you know what I
was doing basically I was going around I
went to come
kosovski Hotel here in in maidan and I
found the place I didn't know I just
went there because I remember it was I
did not but then I I discovered the key
it was much more alive and well
organized than I thought you know when
you enter in a war situation you always
think the worst then you discover people
who leave children I mean there is a
normal life but it takes time
and they of course I would worry
and I remember that I was looking for
food
and they played with a generator because
when you are in war the generator you
need electricity I'm not a tourist I
need to send my stories I found a person
from who spoke Italian by chance by the
poor luck walking in the street and he
offered me a place where to sleep so I
said okay I will have an emergency
Refuge the Russia will enter I would
like I can hide
so that was my attitude it took me as I
told you till the first of March when I
realized it first of all yeah there was
a very large resistance movement
that if a Russian would have entered
physically in Kiev would have been a
bloodshed
Barry gave Molotov cocktail was serious
but I would expect in a huge world in
the city
thank you
and something else happened and this is
a kind of lack of the unfortunate
I was shopping literally near maidan I
found there was a little Supermarket
open very few people were going around
and I had to buy I took I took food in
canned food I took you know bread
a water bottle
and there was a guy who was a colonel in
the air defense unit who just got on
pension last year and he had a lot of
friends and that was I think was about
the the last day of February 28 or the
first of March and he told me the story
of ostomel which we didn't know and told
me hey wait a second I tell you what
happened
and I believe him you look very he gave
me circumstance there was some rumor
about the Austin male battle but there
were still rumors and he told me on the
story he said hey they're not entering
we defeated the first battle
of the real battle well ostomel and the
Russian plan failed there Putin wanted
to take care if you are he couldn't and
now it's another War
I failed if the first operation which
was to capture Kiev with the you know
with special Squad special unit and I
this guy gave me all the detail which
unit how many soldiers you know that's
the three you you Shin 76 air airplane
transport troops which were shot down in
the air or on the ground and they lost
about 600 Soldiers the first few hours
these Soldier were one to supposed to
arrive in Kiev to join with the local
sleeping cell
killed the landscape and take the city
but when this plant failed the Russian
didn't have a plan B
it took me about a week but then I
understood this point
that's why I called my paper
and that what happened in in those first
days and then I thought it's another War
and I thought that makes sense on what I
see on the ground
because there was a story coming out
from
local forces the the you remember the
famous Convoy there is a Russian Convoy
60 kilo 60 kilometers I mean I don't
know how many vehicles
which is and he never arrived
and there was a story without talking
with the local soldier of very agile
little Ukrainian unit with the javelin
and the luau missiles attacking them on
the flank and for me it was clear that
something went wrong the Russia were not
coming in
thank you
[Music]
there are two main elements in this war
which
makes some difference with the previous
war
the first one
this is a mainly a conventional War
so the last war which I really followed
as a conventional war was the beginning
of the American invasion of Iraq in
2003. it was the beginning because the
real world was not during The Invasion
the months of the invasion between March
and April 2003 but was the Guerilla war
after which was mainly terrorism
non-conventional forces with standing
army against group of Guerrilla here we
have mainly a conventional War we have
standing army the Russian army
organizing who say second world war Army
against the Ukrainian Army of course
there are many volunteers but these
volunteers are organized as an army the
second element which characterized the
war in in Ukraine is that
and that I would say is the most
important element for us for me as a
European as an Italian is that this is a
European War
European
a disillusion this Western European add
this illusion namely that the war was
something which didn't affect us was
something for primitive people from the
Middle East from Afghanistan Pakistan
but we were clean the war was and ended
in 1945 and thank God we had NATO we had
the international organization so the
war didn't concern us if the world
doesn't concern us the main idea was
that if you are Advanced and civilized
person or or you have a a diplomatic
apparatus you have a state organized
then you can solve conflict with
dialogue with negotiation with diplomacy
we were living in a world which was not
real
because America this umbrella protecting
us
and because the power of force the rule
the Primitive rule of war was always
there
violence was all around us we just we
simply didn't want to look at
[Music]
start by putting prove my point that the
rule of force the power of initial which
decide with the
with an army to invade another one just
simply because it feels he thinks he's
stronger he's still there
and we have to learn how to defend
ourselves that's why I really look at
this Ukrainian resistance kind of a
teaching lesson like a a a a a a a a
place a situation what you have to look
at and learn a lot that's why I consider
Ukraine like a kind of
avant-garde of our resistance and a
place where we have to learn how to
think back our conception our vision our
situation our position in the world and
to learn that in order to if you have
value as I think we have
democracy freedom freedom of the press I
believe very much as a journalists in
freedom of the press then you have to be
ready to defend it also with guns also
with violence you have two situations
which you know one look like 10 years
ago but is one year ago a very recent
Afghanistan
which I follow thoroughly last year and
here
the Afghans
who were our allies
we after 2001 we tried to recreate
Afghanistan The Afghani Army Italian
were there we had a big contingent there
was a moment in which Italy had 5 000
soldiers in Afghanistan with weapons
with organization and uh
they failed
they were defeated I think we have a big
responsibility in that Afghan girl
cannot go to school
Afghan women have to cover themselves
Afghan men have to have beard and to
have to have the shower hamis the local
dresses there is a theocracy very
dangerous and and terrorism is going
back the Afghan didn't send themselves
didn't die for their freedom or not
enough
and the result is slavery
it's a situation which many of them are
thrown out to escape
endangered for the world
here Ukrainian are resisting
they are defending their freedom they're
defending their Liberties in
Independence
[Music]
the social media internet the quick way
of communication the new way of
communication the globalization
it's a factor also in positive way I
tell you something and let's talk about
something different the Syrian scenario
which has to do with you by the way but
the Syrian scenario Bashar Assad the
father of Assets in 1981 killed the
number is always not precise between 15
15 even till 30 000 people in Hama the
famous Hama Massacre and the Hama
Massacre remember Thomas Friedman who
was my colleague in Jerusalem I mean it
was before me in Beirut writing a book
an article about that one two or three
months later in the early 80s came out
that Bashar Assad killed so many people
were so connected to the fundamentalists
Syria today Santa Clara there could not
happen and Ukraine could not happen I
mean the social media can be confusing
can be but at one point you know
something happened because they come out
you have images you have stories if the
Russians are going to kill 10 000 people
in Carson at one point didn't come out
once it was it was possible to cover it
up or maybe to know it 20 years later
but not now
so you have to follow what happened and
of course you can fake it up you can
take a picture of a situation put it in
in one and say this Curson and instead
of Bahamut but still you can you know
you can work on it
[Music]
at the beginning the real point for me
was that the Russians were lying
and that came and I used to say I say
that many times at the beginning rash a
Putin told us as I was saying before
till really few hours before till the
famous speech when he said he was coming
here to free the the poor Ukrainian from
the Nazi but till the famous speech of
course he wrote the famous article last
year in in July but that was an article
and
it was not taken so much seriously but
till few hours until few days he claimed
that they were no they would have not
they would have not been an invasion
they were doing just training with the
pillow Russia and they were moving this
group but there was all the um when he
did it
I say this is a lie put in his line and
we have to be very careful as when at
the end of the month clearly lost the
battle of Kiev because it was a big
defeat for the Russia and he started
claiming no no we never wanted to kick
here we just wanted to go the dead on
bus Which also rocks somehow in good
faith on this on this point was that the
left himself and by then criticized
zelensky saying you see we told you and
and he told him you are not ready
because it's true the Ukrainian were
thinking something big in the bus an
enlargement of the occupation maybe
going to the border of the donbath
that's it they were not thinking they're
not imagining something so I say okay
here there's an aggressor
who is lying and a a victim who had been
aggressed who had been attacked who were
not ready
so when the Russian talked about
provocation Etc is all [__] because
it's no provocation it's the Russian
were lying and they want to attack and
they look for a Castle's belly as you
say in later
it protects to attack as it is now for
the dirty bomb
and many other I don't have to all the
story of the dam uh on the on the nearby
River Etc so basically I would say the
Russians are lying
foreign
[Music]
there was
after the war the second world war the
strongest Communist Party
in Europe in Western Europe Italian
Communist party was almost winning the
elections in 1946
that's very important the Italian
Communist party was historically
culturally deeply connected with Russia
Italian culture Italian fashion Italian
way of living was very much liked and
and they were around in Russia different
very famous Italian artists have still
gone to to Russia to perform so this is
one Element
the second element which is also very
much entrenched very much deeply
connected to the European and the
Italian
intellectual Elite
is the anti-americanism
there is an anti-American feeling which
is hard to believe
it's hard to compress it's difficult to
comprehend but it's still there this
idea that Putin is trying to spread
which was spread and it was an argument
of the interview I just two days ago
with zelensky Berlusconi
in the parliament three days ago blue
Coney is now a senior member of the new
Italian government
repeating
the the rescue told me repeating the
same wording the same sentence of Putin
we are attacking because
zelensky attacked us because didn't keep
the war didn't keep the the agreement so
we have to defend ourselves
perusconi repeated that in Opel in the
parliament with some of member of his uh
party and it was recorded and he became
a big scandal
and is somehow accepted so this idea
this is not
a Russian invasion
but it's an American
organized plot
to weaken Russia another idea which is
very well spread in in Italy and in the
west Putin has to defend because NATO is
expanding
which is totally not true
totally not true NATO was so weak in the
last years they didn't they lost their
raise on that it was putting which
revealed the reason that of of NATO the
reason to be in it to be strong because
Russia Russia is back otherwise NATO was
dismantling
was Vanishing
Trump was right Donald Trump was that
was right to us to the uh to the partner
in Europe you want to keep NATO pay
money
participate to expenses Italy spent less
than two percent with his own defense
and all the rest now Germany decide to
rearm and it's creating problem with
French with France because Europe we
talk about Europa Europe is a very
articulated animal so
the the the this idea that this war
is
is the result of NATO expansionist which
is threatening Russia
the vital Russian interest
even the Pope the disease we call it
Cato communismo in
italygo there is there are some communal
value and this cattle Community we have
a big two big tradition in Italy the
Christian tradition and the Communists
and on some point they they are together
especially on the anti-americanism
anti-capitalismo opposed to the
imperialists to the Americans this
culture is deeply entrenched in Italy
the liberal culture the Democratic
country is much less important is a
minority I tell you I had some some
effects in my work because I'm here
my only that's why I'm so long so much
here and why in spite or I try to be on
the ground I try to be I see it
you know in Italy when there was the
first story the New York time but
everybody the butcher massacres
they were saying there was no they were
bodies they were not I mean Russian
propaganda they were repeating is not
true the journalists were there are paid
by CIA
so I mean so I I remember one day there
was someone said I am a CIA agent you
think I get money from CIA please see I
pay me because I would like to to get my
salary what are talking about
and this is you know the first
my argument is one I tell you what is my
argument is do you remember
the first 48 hour the American
and tell him take up get out they want
to kill you get out we take you to
Poland
Moldavia or whatever outside
and there you organize
a government in Exile you organize your
resistance but you know they want to
kill you we save you you're created to
stay even the Americans didn't believe
the Ukrainian were not would have
resisted
and what happened
say no
and this change a narrative things
change a story I will die here the
Americans were not interested in
actually didn't want this war because
the main argument the main problem since
Barack Obama up till today for American
China
and for them at the beginning not now
changed but at the beginning this was a
diversion for the major problem which
was Pacific Ocean Taiwan China and the
dictatorship there they really want to
take it out the Americans have
a lot of you know problems they make a
lot of mistakes but the Intelligence on
Russia because of historical reason is
quite good as we can see
and they knew that the American the
Russian army is not so strong
as Putin claim
they built very well in Syria they were
able to capitalize to the weakness of
the west by the way to French Italy in
Libya
and they have this now they broadcast
this image of superpower which are not
at all as you can see this is not at all
an American
Military operation is not a plot to
attack Russia at all
but in Italy this war is perceived more
and more like that and this new
government not Premier Milani not tayani
the foreign minister at all it was by
the way the president of the European
Parliament is very Atlantis but
many of the important relevant
components of the new unfortunately of
the new Italian government are deeply
pro-russian
[Music]
I go a lot in
Italian
journalist school you know also the
university there are now faculty of
Journalism go to the field
go to the field Don't Be Afraid stay
there weeks not days
if you go to go to back mode go sleeping
incrementos go to bank mode don't
sleeping
go and see around talk with people go to
the ground
assistant
yesterday
goldfish
is
foreign
resistance is volunteer
this country it sounds a bit rhetorical
but it's not
it's a you know zelensky is not Leading
the People the landscape is Incarnation
let me use this very Catholic word
Incarnation the spokesman of his own
people this was a a a a willpower there
was a a
determination to resist which was which
impressed me and for me I can finish
with this sentence this is a very good
lesson for a week
European Democracies means
freedom freedom of the press which I
insist Liberty democracy pluralism must
be defended even with weapons and you
need people ready to die so there could
they have to be convinced that they are
defending something which is right and
here there are people who constantly
tell me women and men young and old
who tell me I'm willing to fight and to
die
because I've been here before I was in a
lot in Odessa and I found people who
were before
not so anti-ration at all actually
pro-ration Russian speaker
connected to Russian culture they have
relative in some peterborg and in Moscow
they now cut to the families
the boomerang effect of this invasion
was to push people to be anti-russian
when they were not
[Music]
like very much Odessa but I tell you if
I will stay here I will tell you why but
if I will stay here and I use a text to
write a story I want to go to the I like
imaginary so I will get to see the car
parts in winter but yes because well
because it's a cause you can feel
history
you can in in the building you see this
flourish of uh
uh different cultures
it's very Cosmopolitan you can see the
Cosmopolitan passed the beauty of the
also I tell you something I would as a
Mediterranean
I love Mediterranean and I was very
suspicious about the Black Sea I only
can see candle because I've been in
Istanbul a lot and in very very polluted
Istanbul or marmares lake
sea while here is quite clean and a good
fish but I like really I like this air
these
atmosphere of Cosmo of openness of Cosmo
Cosmopolis
cosmopolitanism of
pluralism I like it very much